- HEY, BELIZE, WHAT'S UP?
- WHAT ARE YOU DOING?
THIS LOOKS COOL.
- AW, YOU KNOW,
JUST TAGGING THIS YOGA STUDIO,
TEACHING 'EM
TO STRETCH SOMETHING IMPORTANT--
THEIR MINDS.
- I THOUGHT YOU GUYS
WERE GOING AFTER,
LIKE, BUSINESS DUDES
AND BANKS AND STUFF.
- WE ALREADY FOUGHT THE BANKS.
OKAY, BUT THIS
SO-CALLED YOGA STUDIO
HAS TAKEN
AN ANCIENT INDIAN ART FORM
AND MUTATED IT
INTO [bleep] JAZZERCISE
FOR RICH MOMS
AND HOMOSEXUALS.
- I COULDN'T UNDERSTAND
A WORD HE WAS SAYING.
- WHAT'S UP WITH YOU ANYWAY?
YOU LOOK PAINED.
TALK TO ME.
- WELL, A COUPLE OF MY FRIENDS
DITCHED ME TONIGHT
TO HANG OUT WITH
THIS BIG BOSS MAN, YOU KNOW.
GUY WAS ACTING LIKE THE SECOND
COMING OF MASTER P, YOU KNOW?
YOU HEARD ME?
[laughs]
HE WAS A JERK.
LOOKS LIKE A CALIFORNIA RAISIN.
- DO YOU LIKE LIVING
IN THAT CAVE OF YOURS?
HOW ABOUT YOU COME
OUT OF THE CAVE INTO THE LIGHT?
- PREACH.
- AKA REALITY,
AKA CONSCIOUSNESS.
- MM-HMM.
- YOU SHOULD COME HANG
WITH US TONIGHT.
- YEAH, MAN.
YOU SHOULD COME HANG WITH US.
- DID I SAY YOU COULD STOP
PAINTING, BITCH?
- NO, SIR. I'M SORRY, SIR.
I AM YOUR BITCH, SIR.